so good morning or good afternoon to
everyone I'm Michele Dunne in the office
of the Associate Director for data
science at NIH it gives me great
pleasure today to introduce dr. Brian
CAFO who is the professor in
biostatistics at the Johns Hopkins
School of Public Health here my who is
my neighbor here in Maryland down the
street he is world-famous as the
co-creator and co-director of the
Coursera data science specialization and
if I remember correctly his group was
even the one that suggested the idea of
a specialization to Coursera he is also
the co-creator and co-director of the
smart group smart stands for statistical
methods and applications for research in
technology and this group focuses on
statistical methods for biological
signals so Brian's research is in
statistical computing and generalized
linear mixed models with applications to
neuroimaging functional magnetic
resonance
resonance imaging and image processing
in general he is well entrenched in the
analysis of big data leading teams to
work in prediction competitions a couple
of the notable ones that his team has
done well in are the ADHD 200 prediction
competition which they won and the
heritage health prediction competition
which they got 12 Ison so
congratulations on those dr. CAFO has
got has been given numerous awards and I
list a couple of them here the first one
is the P case award which is the
presidential early career award for
scientists and engineers this is
probably the most prestigious award that
can be given to an early career
researcher he's also won awards for
teaching and for mentor
so with that I will turn it over to dr.
Brian castle Brian thank you very much
for being with us today thanks Michelle
I hope everyone can hear me thank you
for inviting me and you know thanks for
crystal for doing all the organization
so my topic today is exploratory data
analysis and I'm gonna talk about this
more like an instructor of an
exploratory data analysis because it's
an area that I use a lot but it's
certainly not an area that I do a lot of
active research in I do have one notable
exception so my my former PhD student
named Bruce Swihart who's a really
brilliant guy he works at the NIH now we
wrote a paper that was really about you
know contributing the idea of using heat
maps to perform visualization for
longitudinal data analysis and he has
probably the best title of any paper
I've ever written for certain it called
lasagna plots a saucy alternative to
spaghetti plots so if you want to see
like a nice little paper on
visualization check out Bruce's paper
but the fundamental idea I'll just cover
this really quickly is that you know
with spaghetti plots like in this
hopefully everyone can see my cursor if
you if you if you can't maybe someone
let me know like this this big black
mess over here is just a lot of over
plotting from spaghetti plots if you you
know in cases like this you might want
to do something like put it into a heat
map where you can actually see trends
like here we were investigating sleep
disorder breathing and some EEG signals
and you see some interesting missing
data patterns you also see you know just
generally that the sleep disorder
breathing subjects have like more red
than than the non sleep disorder
breathing subjects anyway it's a nice
little paper it's on PubMed mostly what
I'm going to talk about today is sort of
principles of exploratory data analysis
if you want kind of a lot of practical
information about data exploratory data
analysis in other word
if you want to know how do I do
exploratory de Nile's in our and
specific or Python in specific or SAS
and specific or something like that
certainly the best resource for our I
would say as Roger pangs exploratory
data analysis with our book it's just
all about how do I do it not why do I do
it or what are some of the guiding
principles of how you do it which is
what I'll talk about today he also has a
Coursera course I should make him a
small comment it was actually a Coursera
that came up with the idea of a
specialization but we jumped on it
rather quickly to our credit and then of
course the Bible of exploratory data
analysis is John Tootie's book if you
can if you can find a copy of that but
these two but the this book by Roger
pang in his course are very good like
practical how-to type books and today
what I'm going to cover are things that
are really don't apply across however
you're doing exploratory day now so is
whether you're doing in Python or R or
whatever so let me just start by saying
what exploratory data analysis is and if
I'm going to define what exploratory
data analysis is I should define what
statistical active activities are not
exploratory day analysis so the
traditional dichotomy that people talk
about is to differentiate between
exploratory data analysis EDA and
confirmatory data analysis CDA so
exploratory data analysis focuses on
discovery and hypothesis generation
whereas confirmatory data analysis tends
to focus on hypothesis confirmation
exploratory data analysis still controls
error rates and performs uncertainty
quantification but it tends to do that
much more loosely confirmatory data
analysis tends to focus on formal in
French formal inference and prediction
techniques both of them can use the same
methods the difference is exploratory
data analysis tends to be more freeform
and less structured and I and I liken it
to sort of improvisational jazz and then
CDA is is a little bit more prescriptive
protocol lized and planned and so I have
a picture of a symphony down there so I
think you know that that kind of
differentiates the idea behind it to the
two techniques I would say in general
that data analysis falls on a spectrum
between the highly
descriptive and formal conformity data
analysis sort of ideal and that's
probably most realized in the area of
highly regulated clinical trials so
where clinical trials tend to be highly
protocol eyes and regular eyes
especially in drug development and then
you know there are some areas like
high-throughput technological
measurement areas like genomic stick
tends to fall in this category where
things are a little bit more exploratory
in nature and so I think things though
typically most analyses fall in some
gray zone between the two so I actually
often think the EDA versus CDA division
is more useful conceptually than
practically and then you know I would
say you know maybe an alternate
dichotomy if you really have to have a
dichotomy is to think about whether or
not you're using strongly phrased
statists ient if ik hypothesis to drive
your research versus doing purely
empirical studies I think that's a more
useful division but you know and I
actually put some some papers down here
that discuss some of these issues for
example this this paper by Kellan Oliver
that says here's the evidence now what's
the hypothesis and it talks about the
roles of inductive and versus hypothesis
driven science engineers and then this
great blog post by simply statistics
where says the key word in data science
is not data it's science therefore you
know obviously promoting this kind of
strong hypothesis-driven research agenda
so and then again I haven't really
defined EDA or really going into much
about the specifics of EDA but I want to
you know put one of the the biggest
points that's generally brought up about
EDA versus EDA now is the idea of doing
a lot of exploratory analysis and then
prevent it presenting only the final
step as if that was the only step that
you did and that particular process is
called peat hacking or data you know or
phishing or that so fishing expeditions
or that sort of thing and it generally
falls under the rubric of the more you
use your data for hypothesis generation
and exploration the harder it gets to
really control the error rates on the on
the same data for some sort of final
analysis and I would say there's been a
lot of research in the past couple years
on the extent
sequences of this problem so probably
most notable was ayan Edie's very famous
article that said why most published
research findings are false that I found
this other great article on the extent
and consequences of P hacking and
science which I thought was was also
very interesting and then Jeff Leake and
Leah Yeager who are a jogger who are
here in the department with me both
really great researchers you know really
tried to put some numbers on this idea
of the the rate of false positive
findings in science and they gave an
estimate of the false discovery rate in
the top medical literature so I would
suggest you read all these literature's
in literature and uh and maybe even in
the broader literature in this area if
you're interested in this problem on
using exploratory data analysis too much
to the point where it's sort of biases
your current form Ettore results but
that is a big warning about you know big
a big no-no is to do a lot of
exploratory data analysis and then
present the final step as if it was
confirmatory so now let me actually get
to the topic of exploratory data
analysis so I'm gonna give this is a
shout out to Jeff Leake who teaches
exploratory data analysis in his class
I've borrowed a lot of slides from him
um he had this great breakdown of what
he thinks of it's the steps in an
exploratory analysis and I think it's a
really nice summary and these are
reading in the data kind of figuring out
the data you know after you read it in
you really just you know you need to
figure out what the columns are that
sort of thing pre-processing it looking
at dimensions and making sure they
measure up especially if you have more
than one data set that you're trying to
merge together you have to look at its
values make sure there's no weird values
you need to make tables and hunt for
messed up values figure out how missing
data is coded n a it stands for missing
data how a missing data is coded how
much missing data is there is missing
data coded consistently and then you
want to do a lot of plots plots are sort
of the cornerstone of exploratory data
analysis and then the final step says
don't fool yourself so today and I'll
talk more about that but today really
these are the things I'm going to focus
on and there's a lot of content in
exploratory data analysis in a lot of
content in these
I'm not gonna cover but just in a
one-hour talk I certainly can't I can't
get them all so I'm it's been a little
bit of time on pre-processing a little
bit of a little bit of time on not
fooling yourself and a lot of time on
some some basic guidance on creating
plots so let's talk about pre-processing
so we recently had a really wonderful
talk from Jenny Brian who's a very
notable data scientist who works at UBC
but then also just got hired by our
studio to be part of their educational
and development team and you know there
aren't a lot of great principles in
pre-processing there's almost like it's
almost like an artistic endeavor where
you you you do it differently for every
problem and I think one of the things if
I'm thinking broadly about what her her
basic research agenda is is to really
try and synthesize this process into
some general principles and one general
principle she said which i think is a
very useful one is to try and get
everything into a rectangle and she
actually had this picture of a rectangle
that would like angel wings on it and
you know let me just you know expand on
this a little bit she really emphasized
this idea that data wrangling is work so
if you spend a day or two days getting
your data into a nice format don't don't
think of that as well I haven't even
started working yet the reality is
you've done a lot of work and some of
the most important work it's sort of
like yeah the most exciting part of
building a house is seeing it all come
together and getting a lot of the nice
finishing touches but without laying the
concrete for forum five a firm
foundation for the rest of the house is
irrelevant and so no one likes laying
the foundation but everyone thinks it's
you know probably one of the most
valuable parts of building a house and
and I put that into this quote that that
would say no one has ever said I really
regret getting my data into such a well
organized and thought-out format so some
basic things you want to remember is to
try and save your steps while you're
doing it use a version control system
like get try and engage in reproducible
research as you're doing this and then
her point was also trying get your data
into a rectangle name your columns with
a sensible naming convention use names
that are amenable to
for packages so don't put spaces and
quotation marks and weird symbols and
other things that aren't useful for
coding and your names you know try and
use use capitalization and spacing in
your column names like you're a
programmer no special features if you're
using a spreadsheet
don't put embedded graphs in your basic
data format is try and split that out
split that process out even if you're
using Excel to perform your data
analysis try and you know create copies
of the data set you know where you where
you record how you've created the copy
and create graphs and different sheets
you know don't use numbers for missing
values is sort of one that comes up for
me a lot where people code missing
values is 888 and then the it gets right
into a software package that doesn't
recognize that and treats it as a number
it messes up the analysis and usually
you can detect that very quickly but if
you don't then it messes everything up
okay and there's some tools again I'm
not going to spend a lot of this talk
talking about tools but in our if you
like to use our there's a grammar of
data wrangling that's coming about it's
under development but tools like deep
liar and tidy tidy are and per and and
string are and these things are really
making a lot easier in our and specific
of course you you you you can do data
wrangling in in any of the major
analysis programs now let me talk about
not fooling yourself and I'm the first
thing I'm going to do when I talk about
not fooling yourself is give a couple of
kind of parables that that go along with
this so the first is the famous one of
the elephant and the blind men if this
this picture was awful Wikipedia and
it's the the story of the elephant in
the blind man is that you know the six
blind men are investigating an elephant
and one of them touches its side and
says it's a wall and another touches a
trunk and says it's a snake and I was
trying you get the picture they all got
a very incomplete picture of the
elephant and this parable is used to
illustrate several points but I think
kind of germane to our discussion is
you're really you know you know don't
don't be like the blind man
investigating the elephant
that or at least acknowledged that you
are like that in the sense that you get
you only get to work with the data that
you get to see you know another thing
that's that's very common is is this
kind of bias that you get by finding
something you know finding a pattern and
then pretending like it was what you
were searching for to begin with and
this is most often described as shooting
an arrow and painting a bull's-eye
around where it lands I actually found
online a company called the bullseye
painting company so I think they don't
actually paint bull's-eyes I think they
bullseye is just their name but any rate
that's that's an important consideration
when you're doing exploratory data
analysis is coming up with a chance
finding and then pretending like it was
something you were searching for all
along then there's this famous mutton
Jeff camp cartoon I got this from quote
Investigator where it's a drunk looking
for his corridor underneath the lamppost
as I'm looking for my quarter that I
dropped in the policeman says did you
drop it here and drunk says no I dropped
it two blocks down the street and then
he says well why are you looking for it
here it says in the drug says because
the light is better here and the idea is
that you know you're again you're
looking at the data that you have with
the biases that it has and you know you
know we want to as much as little as
possible be like drunks looking for our
change under under a lamppost looking
where there's light rather than looking
where we need to be looking and then of
course the one that that comes up the
most and most people are aware of is
this problem of multiplicity and this is
a great xkcd comic book it's number
eight 82 and in this comic book the
scientist um one says jelly beans cause
acne and another person says scientist
investigate then the scientists look and
says we found no link between jelly
beans and acne then someone says then
the person says I hear that it's only a
certain color and then they start
investigating all the colors and then
basically all these panels are people
investigating different colors and then
they find green does have an association
and then there's a news article that
says green jelly beans are linked to
acne of course what this is illustrating
that is if you keep looking for things
in noise you'll eventually find them um
so suggesting some example common ways
you can fool yourself in exploratory
data analysis so these are some of the
most common ways this can come up
and I'm relate them to the parables so
one thing is just issues with the data
that you have can it even answer the
questions that you're trying to add to
ask that's the that the elephant the
parable of the elephant and the drunkard
of the lamppost both discussed that
point another thing is that true even
even if you find a true thing those true
things may not paint a complete picture
that's of course the story of the
elephant the confirmation bias the idea
that you've you know you you you pretend
like you discover things that you were
just looking for ahead of time and you
just confirm them but ignore the the
evidence that refutes it that's that's
like painting the bull's eye false
findings you know are always a problem
just where he hit chance associations
that's like the bull's eye and the
multiplicity and then of course the the
problem of multiplicity is just
repeatedly looking for things until you
find something so these are all the ways
that you you can you can fool yourself
and I think these problems are more
pronounced in exploratory data analysis
because we're not even pretending that
we have some sort of strict error rate
control that we're trying to go go
through rarely in exploratory data
analysis do you have a highly protocol
eyes version of what you're doing so now
let me let me so that that discusses
ways in which you can fool yourself now
the the rest of the discussion I'm going
to spend entirely talking about inter
ocular content or other words that the
the plots things that hit you right
between the eyes and the idea is that
you know plots are really the
cornerstone of exploratory data analysis
and and then plot there's something
about visual information that you know
pictures really are often worth a
thousand words and there's just
something about them that can really
speak to us and drive home points and
help us discover things that we just a
table or a number or written summary
just just somehow lacks and I'll give a
great example probably the most famous
graph in the in the graph design and in
exploratory data analysis history is
this plot by Minard about the French
invasion in Russia from eighteen 1812
this is generally thought of as one of
the most information rich graphs that
you can you can find it's also just just
kind of beautiful in and of itself and
this is the original graph and then you
know you can see it's the same thing but
but here's a version I grabbed off of
Wikipedia that has the English
translations on it and so what this
graph depicts is as you go from left to
right here this is showing the the
French troops as they marched in to
Russia you know starting here and then
ending and ending up in Moscow down here
you actually see the temperature okay
and the the the relative the path
actually does quite closely mirror the
geographic path that the troops took
right so that this this really does look
like the path they were taking the the
width of the the width of the graph
represents the number of troops at that
particular time and you have the troops
and these little breakout things are our
groups that broke off right that tried
to go a different direction and then the
black line coming back this way is the
retreating troops so this group for
example broke off and then they
retreated and this is the Richard this
for treating group and this is this
retrieving group okay and and what was
interesting historically what happened
was the the French had a very strong
troop they started out with set
collection of troops they started out
with four hundred and twenty-two
thousand okay and the Russians had a
very you know very harsh strategy is
they were going to engage the French
troops and then retreat and then engage
them and then retreat and then as they
retreat retreated they used these
scorched earth protocols where they
would burn all the fields and and and
and and as they retreated the French
troops would have no way to resupply and
so their goal the the way the Russians
were going to win this campaign was just
by basically freezing and starving the
French troops to death with a with a war
of attrition as they as the as the
Russian true
just repeatedly fell back toward Moscow
and you can just see with the width here
the way this graph displays the death
toll it's just it's striking so it
started out with four hundred twenty two
thousand down to a hundred thousand you
can almost feel you know the the cold
and horror as these troops are trying to
cross this river when they get to a
hundred thousand right then with a hit
Moscow and they get to retreat and then
you see down here back at the very
beginning ten thousands of troops so a
loss of over four hundred thousand
troops in this March anyway at the same
time you can see the the the temperature
along the along the bottom axis here
helping you know show when the
temperature spikes
you know caused large troop losses
anyway really wonderful graph and it's
just a highlight of how graphs can can
be used to just you know use beautifully
in a rate this this is such a famous
graph I thought I'd describe it um
here's another famous plot that really
talked that really helps us more easily
drill down on why plots are inherently
useful so Anscombe was a was a very
famous statistician and he created a
data set where the the mean of the X is
the mean of the Y's the correlation
between the X's and the Y's and hence
the r-squared value and the slope of the
regression line and the standard
deviation the axis standard deviation
was these were all the same matched from
these graphs and so if you ran these in
a regression model or a correlation or
you did a basic summaries like mean of X
mean of Y standard deviation X standard
deviation Y you would get the same
answer for each of these four graphs
however obviously there's very different
stories being told by the four graphs
this one looks like a kind of just a
regular noisy regression relationship
this one clearly looks like a noise free
parabolic curve this one looks like a
noise free line with one outlier this
one has almost no variation in the X
variable except one point that's way
outside of the data cloud so in all
these cases the the unless you had done
the graph if you had just done the kind
of obvious summaries you would miss this
incredibly different story from each
these four datasets and he did this
exactly to make it as striking as
possible another great example is lense
to fan ski who's at NC State likes to
trick his students and he creates these
settings where Meru Brescia model and if
you look it looks like the variables
just follow a nice regression model
there's some significant p-values and if
you fail to do a residual plot you could
just run through the analysis figure out
what variables and it might be necessary
and see nothing in particular but what
happens is if you Pro claw your
predicted versus or residual values for
the model he's telling people to start
with you actually get a picture of Bob
Dylan in the residuals and he's written
some some algorithms that show how you
can create whatever picture that you
want in the residuals so he can tell
whether his students did the plot or not
because they would obviously comment hey
there was a picture of Bob Dylan in my
residuals um so I hope that that
illustrates some of the important
reasons of why we why we need to do
plots and then I'm basically going to
spend the rest of the lecture talking
about ways in which we can improve our
plots or some pitfalls to avoid okay so
as some general principles one is by
Tufte which is I think a really great
contribution to the plotting literature
which is to maximize the data to ink
ratio so if you take this slide is these
slides are from carl broman i don't see
it noted on here but i'll add that these
carl broman is a faculty member at
wisconsin is a real expert in
exploratory data analysis so here you
have this great plot we have a response
plotted by the treatment versus control
it has incredible data to ink ratio
because it displays all of the data with
very little ink and then it has this
nice mean plus two standard deviation
confidence intervals for the two groups
an incredible amount of information
recreates the whole dataset in one
simple plot in contrast you could do
this plot as a bar chart two bar charts
and then look at the amount of ink
you're using effectively to display two
numbers the mean for the treatment and
the mean for the control just the the
loss of information going from left to
right in these two plots is simply
incredible but also the increase
in the amount of you know just a toner
from your cartridge that you need to get
the second plot to display two numbers
that you could have just put in a paper
or whatever anyway is is is almost
ludicrous so that's the principle that
Tufte is trying to elucidate is try to
create plots like this one on the left
where you display the data as much as
you can and when in doubt try to devote
ink to data you know to vote or you know
I think probably a useful way to put it
would be information to ink ratio you
want every you know every bit of ink
you're using to display important
information this gray background isn't
adding anything most of these lines
aren't adding anything on the right plot
the the purple you know the it's just
this is not a very informative plot it's
just basically displaying two numbers
another general principle is don't use
3d so here we've taken that same plot
and we've basically ruined it even
further by adding 3d you have this
optical illusion of this corner here
that that doesn't add anything either
and just to really highlight the
principle of why you shouldn't use 3d we
can basically take this plot and remove
all information by the angle at which we
look at it so and this just is hot to me
to bring it to the point of
ludicrousness where you looking straight
down at it and of course now we don't
even display our two numbers this is
just we've removed all information
content from our graph but that's also
showing that as you take this 3d plot
and rotate it a little bit
you're losing information now I work on
brain imaging and very often we use 3d
because the brain is a three-dimensional
object and we're using it very carefully
to try and display information but I
think you can you can say a general
principle is that for ordinary plots
don't use 3d another thing is is logging
so taking the the natural log or log
base 2 or log base 10 can be can be
crucial if the scale you know if orders
of magnitude are important so here's an
example that Carl came up with in a
genomics setting you can see on the
right hand side of this plot it's log
base 10 and you see this interesting
variation in separation between the
groups with a lot of information here is
the same data set unlogged and you see
basically it
like everything zero so if it is the
case that orders of magnitude are
important like you know take for example
an obvious setting like astronomical
distances you're obviously care more
there about orders of magnitude than
anything else
if orders of magnitude are important
than if you look at this this plot in
the way on the right you've lost all the
relevant information by not taking logs
so anyway taking logs is often a very
important thing to do here's another
example Carl came up with and this is a
mean difference plot on the log scale so
it's the log of the ratio of two gene
expression levels and then it's the
average of the two gene expression
levels and you see all this interesting
variation on this plot also what this
does is it takes the scatter plot you
might think well I could plot log
expression level 1 by log expression
level 2 and a scatter plot this
basically does the same thing but
rotates at 45 degrees to get rid of the
the unnecessary blank space and you can
see interesting patterns such as the law
you know the variance of the difference
decreasing by that the increase in the
average log expression rate but you can
also see you know the bulk of the data
it's it's spread out in a nice way if
for example you were to plot this
unlogged as a scatter plot first of all
you have all this unnecessary white
space above and below the collection of
data but as Carl points out 99 percent
of the data is below this red line okay
so you might look at this plot and come
to some conclusions but you're really
only looking at one percent of the data
ok so now the last thing I'd like to
talk about I got I have about maybe 15
minutes left is is kind of the
psychology of plots there's a science of
plots so so let me just talk about you
know for exploratory plots what what are
the some general characteristics so
usually you're making them quickly
you're not you're not you know
finalizing so so I'm not going to talk
about design today right like there
there could be an aspect of once you've
got a plot that conveys all the
information that you want how do you get
it into a super nice design for a reader
for
application okay that's different than
what goes on an exploratory applies the
plots are usually made for you or your
team right as you as you're going
through the data so the goal is for
personal understanding and a large
number of plots are made they're made
quickly generally it is worth spending
some time labeling your axes so if you
can not only have your axes labeled but
also have the units on the of the
measurement on the axis that is
generally better but also the axis and
the tick marks and things like that are
usually cleaned up because otherwise
we'll see that that's a really easy way
to make clocks difficult to understand
is to not have spent any time on your
axes and then colors and size are
primarily used for information like I
said you're not spending an exploratory
data analysis you're not spending a lot
of time on on final colors and things
like that they're used to make it look
nice for presentation you're spending
more time on on information and they're
so especially for them for plotting
there is a you know not terribly well
developed but at least a nice history
and in some great research in what I
would call a theory of EDA and what I
mean by theory of EDA I don't actually
mean the you know the the mathematical
theory that underlies the some some
characteristics of plots that that exist
of course and that's super well
developed but what I'm talking about is
the psychological part of EDA how do we
perceive plots and it's unfortunately
true that we're designed to find
patterns even even when there aren't
aren't any any and and our visual
perception is is then biased by this
humaneness and so again the goal in EDA
just like we discussed earlier it's not
to fool yourself and the the real
pioneer in this in this field is is Bill
Cleveland at least in the in the in the
field of statistics I think there's it's
it's a it's a much bigger research area
now but in the field of statistics he
was a real pioneer of it so I'm going to
talk about some of his early work but
just to get us in the in the mood let me
show you some some slow
where we see some optical illusions
which you know could very realistically
occur the you know something like this
could very realistically occur in an
exploratory data analysis so in this
optical illusion these two middle points
are of the same size but of course
because of the size and distance of the
surrounding points we perceive them to
be different inside a different size
typically thinking this one's smaller
this is sort of some some unintended
framing that's sort of happening so
that's one example this one is I think
this one drives me nuts but you can you
can load up this image into Photoshop or
whatever and check it yourself but the a
and B squares in this plot are actually
the same tone of gray which is I find
amazing so you know the the the
surrounding colors around you know and
this is achieved by the shadowing effect
but but again you know the idea is that
that even if you're trying to compare
something in a plot by tone you know we
can we can have we can actually have
instances where you know our perception
is very much so off by two you know with
respect to tone and that you know the
optical illusions just hone in on this
as and make it as bad as it can possibly
be to highlight this principle so
another important point just to return
to this point about multiplicity and
testing things until you find something
that's true
Hadley Wycombe actually does exactly
formalize this concept and we have
there's a link down there where you take
for example test you know a dataset
let's say this middle one is the is the
real data he actually then permutes and
and plots the per muted some examples of
the primitive data set so that you can
sort of visually perform a hypothesis
test so he's formalizing this idea of a
hypothesis test used done on data
however this point illustrates to us
that whenever we do a plot whenever
make a decision and then do another plot
and make a decision and do another tough
plot these are informal hypothesis tests
these are informal models that were
fitting and so all the problems that
exist that we talked about with formal
models and formal hypothesis tests get
brought into this process just in a
fuzzy way okay um now let me talk about
Cleveland's work because it's so
fundamental and so what he starts with
in in this work this this paper done
where I have the link down here is
really the the Journal of the American
Statistical Association paper is really
the the foundation of this work and is
really just a fundamental paper in this
area and one thing he brings up is this
idea of sort of the the DNA of
perceptual tasks these sort of you know
these these perceptual units and he
basically says we you know we're what
we're going to do is try and break down
graph characteristics and do these
perceptual units so like contrasting
lengths is an example of a of a
perception task comparing angles is an
example of a perception task comparing
direction and area and volume curvature
shading
position on a common scale position on
nine align scale these are all
perception tasks and are probably the
argument he said is well we can kind of
figure out how people do we can isolate
perception tasks test how people do on
them and that will back and form what
kinds of graphs we should be creating so
it take this experiment he did where he
looked at several different types of
percent of specific position and length
type perception tasks such as so in all
these cases the people were comparing
the trying to get an idea at the ratio
of the length of the dotted the to the
the look the ratio of the lengths of the
two dotted bars and and they have type
one where they're right next to each
other another type where they're they're
separated but they're on the same same
scale in the lowest box you know this
one they're they're set they're
separated into histograms this one
they're the top top box separated
and in this one they're right on top of
these others and then he called this the
position and length experiments because
some of these are very in position and
some of these are varying length
comparisons and when when he looks at
this we can see that there are certain
kinds of things this is the log absolute
difference between the actual true ratio
and what the people who were he was
testing what they thought it was so that
so so he saw that you know certain
certain positions are doing better than
other ones and you can kind of guess how
it would have work on this type v the
length one right that's this one where
we're comparing two things that are not
next to each other right it's very hard
to figure out the relationship of these
two things because they're not directly
comparable but these two things type one
we're doing quite well at when they're
right next to each other and on a common
you know compared with a common axis so
but he could quantify that and then he
looked at several different perceptual
units as an example he also looked at
volume ratios of volumes by comparing
things like positions or angles so here
would be something like a pie chart work
we're comparing angles if you're
comparing the volumes of two things
you're really making that comparison by
virtue of the angle of the slice whereas
the bar you know we might consider
comparing it by with the position of the
bars and and we found what they found
was one thing is that these these angle
comparisons were quite terrible
the log absolute difference for the
angle comparisons just was quite
terrible another thing you know one of
the one of the worst examples was if you
had to compare the ratio of two slopes
and you know they looked at you know
whether you know different ways of
displaying the different ways of
displaying the two slopes so you want to
compare the slope from A to B to the
slope from B to C you want to estimate
that ratio and of course if you squash
it in it gets harder to do if you
display it vertically rather than
horizontally it gets harder to do and
we're very bad at doing this but
remember we often make plots where we're
plotting the slopes of two groups and
intrinsically we're asking the reader of
the plot to perform this calculation and
what this research is showing is how
much you squash the plot how much you
stretch it or even the
tasks to begin with is actually quite
difficult for people another interesting
and this is a separate paper another
interesting idea was that the scale
matters quite a bit of the plot so as an
example you know they showed people
scatter plots with suit with the same
correlation and found people recorded
dramatically different correlations
depending on what they varied so here
you know they might show things that
have roughly similar coral correlations
but when they zoom out people actually
say that you know estimate if they
visually estimate the correlation they
say that it's higher when when you zoom
out okay so so again you know our
perception of correlation is dependent
on the scale at which we the arbitrary
scale at which we choose to display the
data here's the results of this
perception task right so what you know
of course if there's zero correlation
people seem to be doing fine and if
there's a hundred percent correlation
people seem to be doing fine but you
know here are these plus the size of the
circle kind of represents the
variability at that point you can see
you know you know it around correlations
are on point six point five point seven
or so people get the worst there they're
the farthest away from from what the
actual correlation was these two other
lines I happen to reread this paper last
night just to say this are they were
trying to figure out what were the best
Geographic models so they think this is
a model for what people are actually
visually modeling rather than than this
which is kind of more more closer to the
truth so they came up with kind of
theories of the geography that that they
think people might might actually be
operating with a good theory of the
geography that people appear not to be
operating with and a bad theory of the
geography that appears to not exactly go
through the data but appears to more
closely correlate with what people are
doing another great paper was by Jeff
Leake who who does some research in this
area using our Coursera classes and he
actually you know had students try the
experiment of how whether or not they
could ascertain significance from a plot
of a correlation from a plot just by
looking at the sky
and and one interesting thing they found
was that people could not do these kinds
of tasks but you could train them so
that they were able to do it and they
broke it down by different category you
know different categories of how of
things that they could change they broke
down the accuracy by different ways in
which they they changed the way the the
plot was was displayed you know axis
scale whether or not they put a low
s-curve in there you know the smaller
end versus larger end and and in showed
versus accuracy but an interesting
component of this article was was a that
they were able to break down you know
the the various components that that
that impact of whether or not people
were able to surmise these p-values but
then it also they also you know saw this
training effect so some basic summaries
whenever possible use common scales one
of the perception results was you know
when you when you mess up the scales
when you have two plots right next to
each other and one of them is on one
scale and the other ones on another
scale that that the comparison that
translation mentally is quite difficult
for people so when possible use position
comparisons you know things that are on
the same scale in this you know just
measuring you know measuring where they
are relative to that scale you know
basically asking where two things are
when they fall on a ruler that those are
the best things that people are the best
at the one of the things they were the
worst at was angle comparisons so
they're very hard for people to do and a
consequence of this is it basically says
that that people are no good at
interpreting pie charts things like
three like we mentioned earlier three
dimensions adding a third dimension
generally doesn't add much but also
decreases from people's ability to
perceive things and then again this
point that I that I've raised up several
times during this lecture is you know do
not do not fool yourself about
significance and you know I think Jade
got the slide from Jeff also he makes an
important point about saying either in
either direction so we've talked a lot
about not fooling ourselves in the terms
of not making false positives but you
don't want to then you know
on the other way you can avoid all false
positives by saying everything's junk
nothing is ever significant and you
don't want a head in that direction
either way you want a good compass you
know to guide you I just want to give
some acknowledgement so I got a lot of
these slides from Jeff Lee and Karl
broman and then Jenni Bryan jenever
Allan you know I got some stuff from
xkcd Wikipedia lens to fancy and our
studio and then I think we saved hit
exactly 12:45 so I saved some time for
questions if there are any so thank you
Brian so if there any questions please
type them into the question box
everyone's muted so they can't actually
ask them to keep all 200 people from
asking you at once
but while we're waiting for more to show
up in the question box I have one to ask
you and that's whether you have an
example of where a lack of
pre-processing or a lack of looking at
your data ahead of time has really led
you astray and really messed up your
analysis later on well I think you know
well first certainly anyone who teaches
a statistics class can give you an
instance of when when students when
students have written reports for
example that you know when they don't
look at look at values they get messed
up results so most teachers will do
something like spike in some crazy
values that'll mess up everyone's
results and try and teach people that
lesson early but I think that lesson
isn't it's it's very hard to make that
lesson sticky because I've certainly had
many times in my life where I've gone
through a full analysis thought I found
something super interesting you know
kind of started to like write it up with
you know to share with my collaborators
and then found you know after you know
you know maybe on the way to talk to
them realized oh no the direction of the
effect is the exact
opposite of the direction that I thought
it was going to be and that that science
would dictate and then I you know when I
go back I realize it's always some one
of these sort of errors that you know
that like there was some error in
pre-processing there were some missing
datas that were coded missing data that
was coded as as 888 or 999 that I didn't
catch or there was there were some Erik
values like someone who was you know 200
pounds
being put in as 2000 pounds or something
like that and you know that also reminds
us not only to you know do plots but
also checks you know there's Diagnostics
like DF fits and DF betas and things
like that that really helped us in our
models diagnose these errant values and
it's always worthwhile to do those
things so I mean I can say pretty much
anytime I've ever failed to do the
common steps of doing a lot of plots
checking my regression Diagnostics every
time I don't do that I always wind up
with something screwy and then it just
depends on how far I take it before I
have to go back and check it well that's
very good oh that's a very good lesson
for all of us to learn is to spend time
doing that first but what about do you
have a sense of like what percentage of
your time you spend doing the
exploratory analysis versus a
confirmatory analysis I think that very
much so it depends on what branch of
science that you you live in I think I
live in the discovery science world so
when I work on fMRI and MRI much of my
analysis is really on this you know
discovery side science in and and in
that setting I think a lot more of my
analysis could be described as
exploratory as more toward the
exploratory end so then I would say for
many of those projects I would I would
say a huge chunk of it is exploratory 80
percent or something like that
now there are other settings I work in
where this
setting is more mature and you know like
taking an Alzheimer's disease I think
the the setting because there's so many
people working in Alzheimer's disease we
have a better kind of compass scientific
compass to lead us and in those settings
we tend to go into the analysis with
more directed hypotheses and then I
spend a lot less time you know we tend
to be able to come up with a nice frozen
data set that really is exactly what
we're interested in more often when in
the other cases it seems like we start
out with a data set that we're
interested in we find some interesting
things and then find that we didn't
process the data in the way that was
necessary to answer now these new
questions that arose and then we have to
reprocess and I and I certainly would
think that someone who worked in
clinical trials would would spend a
little bit less time on data processing
pre-processing but I don't know it's you
know that would be an interesting
empirical study would be they actually
get actually numbers about it because
I'm sure what we perceive the amount of
time we spend on data pre-processing is
different weather than what it actually
is yeah I bet so we have a couple
questions in the question box the first
one is about lasagna pot and that is and
whether lasagna pots violate your data
to increase you they do have a lot of
ink that is that it's true but on the
other hand they are displaying the full
data set so the numerator and the
denominator is high in that case so I
don't know if they have a great data to
ink ratio but they do have at least in
our in our estimation tolerable one you
know especially because they tend to
take large data sets and they tend to to
reduce they basically redisplay the
whole data set the key with lasagna
plots is not so much the original plot
because that that's interesting in and
of itself and if you're lucky like in
the sleep experiment where there's some
obvious missing data pattern that that
for whatever the reason was common
across subjects that's great but
probably the the key to the lasagna
plots is some sort of sorting
or organizing arose where you can try to
try to detect patterns but anyway yeah
the point is the point is well-taken
that yeah they do look they do use a lot
of ink okay and then the next question
is about any suggestions that you might
have for software to do EDA
do you have any preferences on on
software or if you gum just give some
advice about what are some things people
might use yes so I use are and then but
I've been using are for a long time so I
use besar which is just ours default
plotting stuff since then in our there's
been a sort of a revolution with this
package called GG plot and GG plot the
the GG plot stands for grammar of
graphics and this was a theory that was
put forward on you know worked on by
starting back I you know I think it
dates back to to Cleveland and other
work at Bell Labs and then goes all the
way forward to Hadley Wickham's work on
it and several other people and then I
forget who the actual inventor of the
the term and the the concepts of grammar
of graphics
anyway this this led to a system that is
then operationalized in the r package
ggplot which is i think one of the most
popular r packages and if you're if you
get used to ggplot people seem to
absolutely love it I use it I find
myself using it more and more but
because I was so used to base are it's
it's hard to it's been hard for me to
switch over and ggplot as implemented in
our basically has two steps one is you
have to work really hard to clean up
your data and get it into a nice format
and and that that's almost a feature of
ggplot in that it forces you to work
really hard on your pre-processing
before you start plotting and then once
you get it in a nice format then you're
off to the races with the plots and then
the actual plotting syntax is quite good
for ggplot so I would recommend that but
you know I would say every statistical
data
analysis program has you know completely
tolerable
you know graphics capabilities and it's
more I think I don't think the the the
tool is is as much the problem now if
you're talking about creating
production-ready graphics I then I think
you know you can get into the specifics
of various platforms one thing I that I
didn't mention that is also that is
quite useful is interactive graphics
that's where you create a plot and you
create sliders or buttons or dialog
boxes and things like that so that you
so that the person who's looking at the
plot whether it's you or whether you're
giving it to someone else can interact
with it and there's increasingly great
great tools for that like plotly as an
example shiny and R as an example for
that and then of course the gold
standard for that is d3 which is the
JavaScript library but it you know
that's that requires a pretty heavy
investment of programming knowledge and
time to master that but there's some
layers like plotly that have been built
on top of d3 and other libraries that
make it kind of easy so you know anyway
i guess the answer the question from my
perspective I use R and I like R and
then if I needed interactive graphics I
would use shiny or plotly um thanks and
there was a comment in here not along
the lines of software but other other
resources or the comment here from Ethan
McMann about a report an e I a report
that he's seen that is useful in this
area can you though in addition to your
comments on software could you give some
advice about where someone might go to
find out more information about EDA I
mean you mentioned a couple you know
some of the some of the leaders in this
area like have a with them and called
Roman Jenny Brian Bill Cleveland and you
also mentioned Roger pengs Coursera
course but other than those going to the
research of the first group or or Rogers
course do you have any other advice for
where to find more resources
so it's a know tolerable book that you
could just pick up anything that really
stands out so there's two aspects to
there's two aspects to EDA and one is
super well-developed and the other is a
little more amorphous so the first
aspect to exploratory data analysis is
the plotting component to it and there
is I think a lot of great materials on
plotting so you know on design there's
tuff T's books on you know kind of the
perception there's all this Cleveland
work on the implementation there's
there's lots of books on specific
plotting implementation there was a
great book written by Nathan Yau on you
know who's who does flowing data you
know look at his his his work on on
graphs I'm trying to think you know
Roger paying has a Roger Pink's course
has has a lot quite a bit of stuff on
graphing the Cleveland actually has a
book on plotting as well kind of a Tufte
style book on plotting there is a boy
I'm forgetting I'm blanking on some
names but but you know there's lots of
books on plotting and then there's the
other aspect of exploratory data
analysis which I didn't get too far into
which is you know you can use models
clustering you know uh you know huge
chunk of tools a kind of what I would
just call modeling tools but but in
general statistical tools can also be
part of exploratory data analysis
regression is a key part of exploratory
data analysis right you you you know you
you fit at a model throw in a confounder
you know check things so and I would say
that's less well-developed as a field
there is you know you know so they're
you know you have to go to books on you
know machine learning or clustering to
look at unsupervised clustering any
regression class will have lectures on
on on how to use regression but they
won't kind of differentiate the use of
regression in EDA versus the use of
regression in a you know in a final
confirmatory annette type
type analysis you know the standard for
that is of course two keys book for that
style of analysis is two keys book it's
it's it's wonderful in that regard so
that would be the starting point and
then I'll think about that maybe on the
slides which are Google Docs I'll add
some references if I can think of some
more okay and I think you just answered
the last question which was commenting
on whether some other techniques like
dimension reduction and collective
variable search would be considered EDA
or could be categorized as EDA and that
sounds like what you what you just
answered yeah absolutely
absolutely I would consider that EDA you
know anything you know easy I guess one
way to define EDA is anything that's not
confirmatory but you know I think when I
when I look at my definition it's it's a
little bit it's not very strict for what
constitutes EDA and I think I define it
more along the lines of Europe if you're
really doing hypothesis generation and
you're really you know kind of doing the
more free-flowing style of analysis
where you're kind of looking for trends
and you're poking and prodding and
you're you're you know you're kind of
developing your hypotheses on the fly
anytime you do that no matter what
techniques you're using I think you're
doing it yet okay great and with that
since we are out of time I want to thank
you again for this great lecture and for
coming here to help us understand this
better
Thank You Bryan no problem thank you Hey
bye-bye